so a father brought his young son into  an elephant enclosure in the san diego  zoo  clearly this is incredibly illegal the  video is  haunting and it's amazing that no one  but the man was arrested and of course  people have asked what is he going to be  charged with well  the obvious things here are probably  criminal trespass just because you have  permission to be in the san diego zoo  generally doesn't mean you can go  into the elephant enclosure or the lion  enclosure then of course there is the  child neglect and child endangerment  here  this is manifestly reckless conduct uh  this is the kind of thing that you don't  want any parent ever doing and it's  definitely not worth the selfies to  endanger your child and this is exactly  the kind of thing that the authorities  are going to take a hard look at  because the father was being incredibly  incredibly stupid  so don't be like this father and don't  endanger your child or i will see you  in court